[Musique]
porte de clichy une des entrées de paris
voilà cinq six ans que des bandes
d'enfants se sont installés aux abords
de la capitale
il y a quelques années c'était des
yougoslaves aujourd'hui ils sont 6
gagnent roumain
abu jamal
pascale bordet pas
pas grave
port
la brigade des mineurs estiment qu'ils
sont près d'un millier à se retrouver
sur les trottoirs de paris ils sont là
pour gagner de l'argent
[Musique]
matt bonne part par jérôme
sommes-nous pas vains car
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à peine dix ans ils sont déjà à la rue a
monnayé leurs services même si la loi
interdit aux mineurs de travailler
et ta mère
vivien harcèlement quotidien des
automobilistes exaspérés et épanouie pas
mieux c'est
non
l'argent ils vont chercher là où il est
dans les lieux touristiques et quand ils
sont trop petits pour faire la manche
ils servent à émouvoir le passant bébé
en celluloïd ou vrai bébé que de fos mer
se repassent d'après la police c'est une
bonne affaire qui rapporterait aux
alentours de 10 millions de francs
chaque année aux adultes qui tire les
ficelles de ces petits pantins
face à cela les juges ne savent pas trop
quoi faire dans ma vie c'est en tant que
telle n'est pas une infraction donc le
mineur est libre de mendier ce que le
législateur a voulu c'est empêcher que
des parents ou des personnes les
autorités sur ces mineurs les oublie
jamais dit ce qui peut être le cas
et dans la situation des mineurs
roumains
reeves 1 elle a 7 ans il y a deux mois
qu'elle a quitté sa roumanie natale pour
faire le voyage jusqu'en france 2 mois
que tous les jours elle se retrouve au
pied de la tour eiffel pour mendier de
10h à 19h il y a deux mois elle a fait
la connaissance de laëtitia qui
l'accompagnent aujourd'hui elles disent
qu'elles censeurs parce qu'ils arrivent
le matin les enfants ont le ventre creux
ils n'ont pas eu de petit déjeuner pour
manger il leur faut avoir gagné les
premières pièces de quoi se payer
quelques coupes faim
que tu recherches sur ces l'argenterie
et après dit les mots j'ai appris la
grave au pédalier l'argent imprimé et
d'argent mais pour moi et m'a pas limogé
tu m
et toi quoi 4h et soitec
18 pourquoi pas sur les mots m'a volé
mon papa c'est vraiment une nouvelle
astuce leur chose un race d'ici à ce que
certains ici les la france voilà mais
belhadj maniche frasques juste c'est pas
nous c'est parfois fait les héros mais
ne devrait pas jouer comme toutes les
petites filles de dommages
19h pour ce groupe la journée de travail
s'achève
[Musique]
et
c'est nous
oui
[Musique]
quarante cinq minutes de train jusqu à
ermont dans le val d'oise à une dizaine
de minutes de la gare l'un des 15 quand
s'ils gagnent localisée autour de paris
une cinquantaine de caravanes dans
chacune d'elles vivent cinq à six
personnes au total une centaine
d'adultes et quelque 200 enfants à leur
retour du travail
celles qui sont de corvée d'eau le
robinet le plus proche se trouve à 15
minutes à pied quinze minutes lorsque le
trafic le permet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'après un chef de clan tzigane l'an
dernier une dizaine d'enfants ont été
renversés par des voitures car les
enfants aussi sont de corvée riva elle
dit qu'elle serait venu en france avec
son petit frère de deux ans à bord d'un
camion conduit par des gens qu'elle ne
connaissait pas c'est à caravanes
oui c'est chez toi études enrichi est à
maman aller où est ton papa ou maman
c'est l'art mal et on papa il nous papa
il est ou la roumanie
départ en roumanie il semble que
beaucoup de ces enfants ne soient pas
venus avec leurs vrais parents chez les
tziganes la famille c'est le clan ici
rivas a trouvé de nouveaux parents maria
la femme au fichu et son mari et ses
filles elle les emmène avec elle et
qu'est ce qu'elles font refiler à la
tour eiffel et ça nous y monde là où ils
vont d'abord parce que c'est joli c'est
pas trop si d'après l'homme qui se
prétend leur père les petites filles ne
ferait donc que du tourisme
médecins du monde à constituer des
équipes qui s'occupent de leur santé le
docteur michèle mézard les suit depuis
trois ans elle les connaît bien
une fois par semaine elles visitent un
des 15 camps de la région parisienne est
ici à paris la préoccupation des
médecins c'est d'abord les infections
pulmonaires
alors qui c'est qui est courageux la
robert robert qui s'est robert george
buffet dans le dos on constate qu' il
n'y a pas d'eau qui a des ordures des
bouts de ferraille de verre qui traînent
par terre des enfants jouent au milieu
de ça il ya beaucoup de poussière
alors quand on voit des dermatoses y en
a eu plusieurs qui sont venus là
aujourd'hui des enfants avec des plaies
infectées quand on voit des dermatoses
on peut l'expliquer je ne peux pas
prouver la mendicité n'ont rien entendu
ceci dit je il ya une tradition dans ces
populations que l'enfant participent à
la vie économique de la famille est la
rumeur selon laquelle les tout petits
les nourrissons seraient droguer pour
passer des journées entières sans
broncher dans les bras des mères en
train de mendier pour moi ces enfants ne
sont pas drogué et je n'ai jamais trouvé
des somnifères dans les caravanes alors
que j'ai fait un inventaire des
pharmacies je pense que ce sont les
enfants qui sont calmés par la mer par
des caresses dans les bras par le 5 on
leur donne je crois je vous ai donné mon
opinion
ça n'est qu'une opinion les nuits semble
paisible pour ceux qui les passe au camp
ce n'est pas le cas de tous les enfants
23h sur les champs elysées
près du grand palais le commissariat du
8ème arrondissement avec une équipe de
nuit pour une mission de routine convie
ce soir c'est essentiellement la
provocation de minéraux la mendicité et
puis également le fait de soustraire le
obligation de soins si on voit des
gamins en très bas âge notamment - d'un
ou deux ans dans les bras de deux
roumaines en train de se livrent à la
mendicité éventuellement des mesures de
placement enfin en accord avec la
brigade des mineurs
voilà voilà pour qu'il y ait provocation
de mineur à la mendicité il faut qu'il y
ait un adulte et établir qu'il contraint
effectivement les enfants à mendier
point de vue technique de police n'est
pas un problème
les interpellés sont huit cavaliers
des risques éventuellement de voir des
gamins
traverser la rue et avec se faire
shooter renversé par une voiture
là ils vont peut-être venir nettoyer
notre propre pare brise on va les
laisser faire je présente là c'est très
rémunérateur une fois on avait
interpellé donc un gamin de 17 ans qui
vous est beau c'est une petite équipe de
2,4 mineures et il avait à peu près de
1500 francs sur lui en pièces de
différents appartements où les gens
contribuent en donnant de l'argent
forcément ça entretient cette mendicité
et ça entretient donc ça c'est l'effet
pervers c'est que ça entretient cette
exploitation des enfants sont des
enfants qui de toute façon mes temps
étaient entretenues dans cette dans
cette éducation pour nécessairement que
donner des délinquances avec
hop
bonsoir tu as police vous lever vous
allez vous nous accompagnent et non pas
le métro non la brigade des mineurs
un art vous le veuillez vous lever et
aller au niveau 5
vos affaires là derrière c'est pas vous
d'accord
la cage elle a quel âge là tu as quel
âge septembre cette chanson
on a maintenant messieurs métro et le
quart police secours d'abord
on va se porter à hauteur de
vous allez vous rapprocher du fouquet's
en attente nous on va les choper les
autres et puis comme ça on va charger
tout le monde
les autres ce sont les laveurs de vitres
lorsque les gens refusent de céder à
leur avant-centre limay été payé pour la
petite bezonnes qu'ils ont effectuée il
est pas rare qui tordent les
essuie-glaces et qui donne des coups de
pieds dans l'est dans les portières
voire même à casser les vitres c'est
arrivé plusieurs fois d'avoir des
véhicules complètement ruinée
au coeur de paris
au lycée
[Musique]
tu as quel âge tu as 12 ans d'accord
rien rien comme d'habitude à ton avis un
parti un mouvement parti quand on porte
les quoi
on va l'emmener au commissariat ouais
pourquoi parce que tu te livrent à la
mendicité parce que tu es en train de
nettoyer un voilà tout ça
donc pour l'instant tu regardes ça
d'accord tu restes là tu bouges pas on
va vous essayez tout cela également tous
tous les jours et en particulier le
week-end la police ramasse une vingtaine
de mineurs tzigane chaque petit groupe à
sa place bien définie pour son activité
quel âge as tu sois disant d'accord dans
ce groupe marius le petit accordéoniste
impeccable majeur
aulas
c'est
les
on voit des enfants qui sont en péril
qui font l'objet d'un véritable négoce
sont les enfants qui sont d'une certaine
façon un esclave dans la mesure où ils
sont éduqués et élevé dans la mendicité
dans la rapide dans la petite
délinquance et on le voit ils ont des
problèmes le sanitaire souvent des
maladies peau et autres ils ont des
problèmes parfois respiratoires
il est une heure du matin passage au
commissariat pour relever les identités
alors il n'y a pas deux mers pour le
même enfant un qui est la maman du dieu
de l'enfant c'est vous le meilleur
d'accord vous la fille d'accord ok bon
bah ouais d'autant plus qu'on a
notamment au moyen de demain de vérifier
comment tu t'appelles et je tombe
famille
1 tu as quel âge presque d'accord ils
ont hockey
est-ce que tu habites ou est-ce que tu
habites ermont 95 lui c'est le banquier
lui un banquier c'est quelqu'un qui a
bien ri l'argent soutiré que reims est
le directeur
tout rassembler on va voir faire les
comptes la seule pièce à conviction
l'argent seulement la recette n'a pas
été retrouvé sur le majeur la procédure
habituelle le capitaine avise la brigade
des mineurs donc interpellation une
heure trente la d'un majeur et de quatre
mineurs d'accord et ont jeté les amène à
l'hommage aux selon remis en liberté
rien n'a pu être retenu contre le majeur
qui accompagnait les laveurs de pare
brise en prix à bientôt
aucune infraction n'a pu être non plus
reproché à la vieille femme bat
logiquement l'a suffisamment d'argent
pour prendre un taxi mes enfants mangent
quelques petits doutes est possible
qu'ils retournent en novembre il est
2h30
de poursuites sont possibles lorsque les
parents manquent à leurs obligations en
particulier lorsqu'ils ne respectent pas
tout tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
assurer la protection des mineurs mais
cette infraction s'applique en tout cas
très difficilement dans nos cieux sont
concrètes de mineurs roumains puisque en
dehors d'une incitation une provocation
à la mendicité
ce sont en général des démineurs qui
font l'objet de soins relativement
satisfaisant de la part de leurs parents
contre l'om reste entier sur
l'obligation scolaire
mais vous savez qu'en france l'aviation
scolaire lorsqu'elle n'est pas respectée
relève du domaine contraventionnelle ce
n'est pas un délit donc une moyenne
poursuit dans la matière sans
et de coercition sont beaucoup plus
limitées dimanche matin il est 3 heures
pour tout le monde
il faut rattraper le temps perdu avec
ces tracasseries policières
des policiers qui parfois ont quand même
l'impression de faire quelque chose de
bien il gamine qui nous avait été
signalé comme ayant été vendu à une
famille de tsiganes dugny en
seine-saint-denis et qui venaient se
livrer à la mendicité sur les champs
elysées et ont réussi donc à interpeller
sa fausse mère entre guillemets qui la
chaperonnais et qu'il a poussée à la
mendicité et cette gamine en fait avait
été vendu par ses propres parents dans
son pays d'origine pour une somme à peu
près de 1500 marque ensuite mariée de
force à un mineur de 14 14 ou 15 ans le
mariage avait été consommé donc en plus
contre son gré donc il ya viol est elle
c'est une victime intégral donc a été
une véritable paria on avait bien vu ce
soir la femme on n'arrêtait pas de se
moquer de l'année ainsi de suite quitte
presque à la frapper une histoire qui
est digne du moyen-age et qu'on retrouve
en 1998 sur les champs elysées 5 heures
du matin l'heure du premier métro le
retour au camp pour l'équipe de nuit
une heure de trajet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour si la police n'a jamais pu
établir qu'il y avait effectivement des
filières en tout cas il y à une bonne
organisation
alors que les femmes d'une autre équipe
celle de jour se prépare pour partir
avec leurs enfants les hommes eux
entament une dure journée
[Musique]
ce sont eux qui s'occupent de la gestion
ils connaissent bien les règles pour
filmer ici il faut avoir le feu vert du
chef
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si vous filmez vous allez avoir des
problèmes avec moi je suis le président
des roms de toute l'europe et de la
terre entière
[Applaudissements]
mais le feu vert ne veut pas dire que
tout le monde parle
les seuls dont on peut tirer quelques
mots ici sont les hommes du conseil
depuis combien de temps êtes vous
installé ainsi je suis arrivé en france
pendant le régime de ceausescu
j'ai pris l'argent de tous les tsiganes
et je suis arrivé ici dont un des
passeport en règle
[Musique]
comment êtes vous venu ici en camion en
train
en camion en camion non un camion
française combien avez vous payé pour le
voyage j'ai payé 1500 marque
il vous a amené directement sur un
campement non le chauffeur m'a laissé un
peu plus loin et moi je me suis rendu
directement à l'offre à l'ofpra l'office
français de protection des réfugiés et
apatrides les roumains connaissent bien
ils savent que la loi française accorde
automatiquement à tout demandeur d'asile
politique un titre de séjour et une
allocation mensuelle de 2000 francs le
temps d'instruire le dossier
nos procédures sont attractifs puisque
la personne bénéficiera automatiquement
un titre de séjour et bénéficiera de
surcroît une subvention vrai qu'un
supplément par enfant alors
naturellement tout ceci est connue est
connu et d'après l'expérience que l'on
en a le bouche à oreille joue à plein